[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on guys uh you should still
be able to hear me
i don't know yet we'll have to see
need uh
need a a one if you can hear me in a two
if you can't hear me in a three if i
sound horrible
i need feedback
feedback is very important to me
all right testing again man look i i
listened to myself i thought i was a
little too loud man i thought i was
gonna blow some your eardrums out i
don't know what happened
my settings on
my uh
my little machine was a little lat with
a little up a little bit but how do i
sound now
i sound like jim ryan
i don't know how i feel about that
we there might be some fighting words
next jim ryan
you know jim ryan doing good for himself
maybe i should sound a little bit like
jim ryan i don't know
maybe i should sound like jim ryan
so so the this is how the podcast going
obviously you can see down there you
know we got a little bit of
talk about that playstation plus 2.0
we're going to talk about that xbox
winning mpds
pretty consistently may i add uh pretty
consistently uh we're gonna talk about
the games being delayed of 2023
you're low b i'm low
okay hold up hold up
let me move my stuff up to a six
all right we're going to
we're gonna go with that
all right how does that sound am i too
loud now
speak now
or forever not hear me
but maybe i should actually
i feel like i should send this
to
to hustle i feel like that might be a
good idea to sit in this dussel
i don't know why
i feel like i should send this to hustle
we are gonna have dirt griggity on uh he
will be on today
uh so you know it's gonna be a good
little show man good little show
we're gonna have dirt griggity on hustle
about to roll up in here
you know
i i'm i'm going to make the best show
possible
there we go
they're officially out
hold up
they can't hear you yet i can hear you
but they can't hear you
yeah you're a little loud a little loud
yeah nick's uh i'm gonna be rotating the
third person now obviously there's gonna
be a lot of times where you know it's
just me and hustle but i will be
rotating that third seat i wanted kids
smooth actually to be the third
permanent seat uh but we couldn't get
times and you know kiss me doing a lot a
lot and you know if i would have
accommodated once like a day he could
have made it i'm pretty sure he would
have done it but he's already doing
planet xbox he's doing weapon well and
to me as a friend
i couldn't just let that dude take on a
third podcast a week
i like dirt man i liked her he he he
definitely
he definitely did uh
a good impressions on me when um
he was on on iop
yeah sometimes he'd be
he'd be
going into the extra stuff but
you know
hold up guys
yeah
oh i know the podcast hasn't started yet
no no i i just
do doing a little bit you know uh
talking a little bit do we already got
90 people in here
yeah when griggity gets here
uh we'll start the show but i'm gonna go
ahead and mute my mic guys i see you
here in about five minutes
or eight eight no seven seven minutes
we'll see you then man we'll see you
then
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
i'm going live
now
what's going on you guys
gaming guys here laura whatever you want
to call me these days i don't know some
of you some of you say i'm a fanboy one
day then i'm the opposite fan for the
next uh but that's besides the point
welcome back to the attic show where we
talk about the past present and future
gaming i got my co-host with me hustle
and motivate how you doing hustle what
have you been playing
so let me ask you the the former first
how am i doing
better than chris rock i'm not gonna
hold you i'm not better than chris
yeah yeah that that man
said that man today that man had murder
on his mind yup hey look i if that
moment from sunday told us anything is
that you kind of got to leave people
alone you don't know what people are
going through because the nicest person
in the world literally snapped and we
saw it anyway well i've been playing to
be fair i'm pretty sure chris is going
to live because did you see that they he
said because his next stand up is like
in august and they sold more tickets for
that stand-up in one day than they did
all year
well i didn't know that
me neither like oh so the name of his
next uh stand-up special is called
killer ego or ego killer i do believe
he's about to kill someone's ego i don't
know if he's going to be his but
it probably is probably his own
everything is a rolo um as far as what
i've been playing
and adding you're the blame for this
i've been playing um the other worlds oh
you've been streaming yeah
yeah i streamed at the one time and i'm
gonna get back to it friday night um of
someone working on like an ninja turtles
video but i'm getting back on it friday
night but that's what i've been playing
man on that you know my my my other
stuff so you know my retro stuff you
know how that go
that's what's up and we we got a guest
we got dirk griggity man how you been
doing and what you've been playing
what's up man thanks for the invite um
i've been playing you know i've been
trying to finish dying like two
and i'll be playing a little wwe 2k 22.
so yeah those are two
games i've been playing lately
brown's been trying to get us to play
that wwe game
it's actually pretty good it's the first
rest of the game in years that i can say
is actually pretty good
yeah i used to play like i guess i was
more interested in the customization and
the old ones old old ones
uh but those days are gone uh so you
know
one thing that i could really you know
stay about
i i think didn't 2k just get the license
for
the wwc games
see like this was what the this was
being said that if this game wwe 2k 22
didn't succeed
wwe was talking to ea but
they resigned with uh 2k so he's still
going to be a 2k for a while
that's good uh because you know
i'm all about
companies getting new opportunities but
you know clearly
they they
maybe that should be like the norm like
it's just like look like if you don't
meet our expectations i don't care about
yours but if you don't meet ours
right you out of there and i think it
may
but you know what eddie let's be real
like it ain't like vince mcmahon never
ever gave a good goddamn about uh wwe
that that the franchise because if he
did
that game was horrible for quite some
time and the engine that they were using
like i guess you know 2020 was like the
last draw though
it was bad it was it was pretty bad this
video was all out there with the
glitches and everything yeah it was
pretty bad yeah hey there's no one like
like dirk said um i know 3mg here i saw
him playing this i'm like look cool but
i might have to take a chance on it man
i might get the console version because
if i don't like it you know i gotta give
it back you know my history goal was all
the way back with like wwf no mercy
would actually go back before that go
back to war zone which was made by
acclaim and go back to attitude yeah
yeah them joints wasn't good well not
n64 for me
yeah and then it was the no mercy stuff
which was like the pinnacle of like that
wrestling style and um yeah i mean you
know they things were taken over um
after thq because thq was running that
for a minute they made the death champ
game step jam uh vendetta death jam
fight from new york and i'm not sure if
they made death jam icon i think ea made
def jam icon yeah that wasn't um
yeah that wasn't that same studio now
that was a different engine and it
wasn't as good not at all that's what i
was gonna say if they was gonna go to ea
they got to be careful but yeah that's
that's good to hear though that's good
yeah hey um hustle you turned on your
mic just a little bit i think that
you're overshooting dirt griggity pretty
hardcore
okay cool let me know how i am now you
sound fine it cut up yours just a tad uh
i think you cutting yours up a little
bit and him cutting his down a little
bit uh because i don't want to turn up
you both of you because i feel like
hustle will be blowing people's eardrums
out but all right so
let
first off
the chat man appreciate it for coming
through here man hit that like button if
you guys don't mind you know we uh i got
i got the artwork being made all right
it's being made right now i don't know
when it's gonna be made i don't know how
long it's gonna be took
because this stuff takes a while
but i i do i got a few things going on i
think you guys gonna like it man
hopefully
i'm hoping to have it before we go to
pax
but i don't know we gotta find out super
chat from warlord
uh 10 15.
i'm late just tuning in what's up guys
griggity is that you you
oh my god oh god
all right what's happening what's
happening yeah i thought he was coming
at you for a second i was like man
i
what did dark grenadine do
but all right all right there's this so
we got some topics to talk about today
we got some topics to talk about you
know there are little things i want to
talk about that's not on this thing uh
you know but we'll get to that here
momentarily
first thing i want to talk about
is games
and the all do you think of them getting
delayed of 2023 because now we just
recently got zelda
that has been pushed to 2023 i'm pretty
sure that um
uh the the justice league mood game that
was pushed back to 2023. uh there's a
lot of games left that's coming out this
year and i'm kind of curious to hear you
guys panel you know dirk are getting
hustle exactly what do you think's gonna
get pushed back and you know we're gonna
start with hustle hustle
gun to the head what's getting pushed
back to 2023
oh no question god of war
oh god
look listen you just made like half the
chat
man it'll be all right wb listen we
ain't heard nothing about nothing
all we heard was uh a lot of piss
getting harassed by so many fanboys
because she was she wanted to play
tonight this is all we heard this is all
we heard we haven't heard anything yet
in regards to ragnarok now if they you
know they got the e3 thing rolling
around i'm sure they'll do something in
june
if one won't see nothing in june boy
i don't know man it's not looking good
it's not looking good um
that's like if you put a gun on my head
that's i'm saying that first and i got a
feeling i'm going to be right i just got
a feeling i'm going to pull back a
little bit on the god of war slander of
it getting pushback because
a community manager did come out and say
that they're still aiming for this year
now for the people on twitter that wants
to
highlight screenshot that post and act
like it's it's definitive that doesn't
mean nothing that literally just means
that they're aiming for 2022. i'm pretty
sure three or four months ago if you
would ask the people of just the league
or the people
for
you know whatever zelda i mean zelda i'm
pretty sure zelda said six months ago
that they were coming out in 2022 like
look
these things they hold close to the
chest
because they need to see how the how
everything's going and then they'll move
it i saw people saying that
that
zelda was being pushed to 2023 because
of horizon
oh no sir no sir
no
yo
the last game
that zelda's scared of is horizon for
pitt and west
or um what's the or else in the ring
like we gonna be real that is nintendo
and well i might not be the biggest fan
of nintendo we we can't lie like the ips
don't do numbers no animal crossing like
listen i'm more surprised that adam and
i just saw nothing do nothing i'm most
surprised that animal crossing did with
it there and then metroid dread did what
it did i'm just
i'm chew through nintendo fans man
yeah i'm not a fan of nintendo either
but the ip sailed in incredible man i
mean we can't deny it yeah but really
what else is there over and out of play
like that's the thing i i i get so sick
and tired of people attacking because
people don't like when i say that look
when you're not selling anything else
but your first party your your consumers
are going to naturally go towards you
like it's just like you know when eldon
ring came out you know kirby's probably
gonna sell well
obviously eldon ring was the talk of the
town for weeks to talk of the internet
it was everywhere i had youtubers
telling me not to make videos until the
elder ring hype was down because all the
videos are flopping because if it's not
about eldon rain it wasn't doing good
but when you're on the switch and
there's no held in ring
and then you oh we finally getting a
kirby obviously
that's probably going to sell better
like what when you when you if if you if
you put a individual you put hustle in a
clocked room and starve this man
and i put like
i put some molded bread in there after
about a week of him not eating i'm
pretty sure hustle gonna eat the molded
bread so he got me like wait why do you
got me locked up in the first place
hey listen that motorbreak one tastes
like a gourmet meal dog like we're gonna
be real but but kirby you know kirby
kind of does well for the most part
anyway and the uh creator sakura whose
name i cannot get right for the for the
life of me you know he did a super smash
brothers so people are like big up on
him anyway he created that franchise
over there at house so
yeah they're going to be big on on kirby
man and it's going
you know it's going to do everything
this is going to do what to do i'm i'm
curious to see what those numbers are
but um now but to get back to the
subject though get back to the matter
ahead god of war is definitely getting
delayed
what do you think
i think that's you you go you go dirt
i agree with them um
uh
i'm sorry because i saw i saw people
saying i was kind of low like am i okay
now or yeah you sound a lot better um
okay hold on let me let me check the uh
i'll check you guys come on volume up
um yeah you know what household i agree
with you man i do think god of war is
the biggest possibility i'm not saying
that's going to happen
but when addie asked the question i
think that's the game that's most likely
to be delayed
um not that it's a bad thing because i'm
sure the game is going to be amazing
um but yeah that's i agree with you i
mean i just think kobe just affected you
know obviously everything in the world
and of course the game industry you know
there's so many games being delayed
so many uh studios just wasn't used to
people working from home and that was a
big adjustment so uh because of that i
believe a lot of games got affected but
you know i think the game will be
quality when it comes out but that's my
answer though i agree with you hustle i
think
that the industry
was affected a lot more than co by
covert than people want to emit
i feel like a lot of games that were
supposed to come out at a certain time
they were automatically delayed six
months
and that's
that's being kind
i mean even games like uh wouldn't
return or delayed
last of us was delayed uh god award has
been delayed like twice at this point
like i don't care what people say that
original
date for 2021 was some of the biggest
bullshitting go at all that's ever been
around
we got gotta find out the superchat from
dawn otaku
you act like most people don't have
another console along with a switch
nintendo fans will buy elder ring and
kirby there's no starving there's
definitely starving over there man
you know that's why you think indie
games like triangle strategy
sign deals for exclusivity on that
platform because they know that they're
not going to sell that well on any other
platforms day one
right
and it's like that's nothing bad like if
anything that's genius like
nintendo
is confident enough with their own first
party stuff that they will they don't
they don't care like imagine what it's
like for a for a console holder to come
out there on a third platform party
look people in the eyes such as
microsoft trillion dollar company sony
trillion dollar billion dollar company
ea billion dollar company look at these
third-party
platforms and so you can keep your [ __ ]
like
like that that's
that's just
they do that they really do that like
yeah but they got to be careful doing
stuff like that too because they'll end
up in a wii u situation yeah like yeah
their game so well but nothing else did
we as we know that we use uh other like
failure it was a disaster i think it may
it might have moved what 13 million i
think it didn't move
that's that's wild
yeah everybody's saying in five years
like that's that ain't wow that's wild
though well yeah oh
i'm not like
i mainly buy their first party stuff
that that's what i buy i buy their first
party stuff so to me
it's like you know the zeldas i bought a
switch day one for zelda i i just beat
triangle strategy sure that's not their
stuff but it's exclusive they went out
it's the kind of game i like to play i
would have preferred it on another
platform to actually run properly i mean
i'm not saying it ran horribly but when
you play it you're like man if only this
is on anything else but the switch
you know uh i kirby ain't my thing i'm
not really gonna touch that now i'm
going to try breath of the wild too i
wasn't a huge fan of the first one
because i felt like it was too much out
of the breath of the wild foundation out
of the zelda foundation but it was good
enough to where it build my curiosity
you know they got they got my interest
now they got to get my no they got my
curiosity now they have to get my
interest all right so it's just like you
know me personally i feel like
there's a chance god of war can come out
this year i'm not gonna say there's not
but i'm gonna say that that that chance
is very slim
like very slow
like i don't think that's happening and
the reason i don't think that's
happening is
unless they're coming out in the next
month
two tops
and they're going to release the game
like two months after that
where is there time to properly market a
game like god of war people's like oh
god we're editing it's gotta work you
don't need a market god award you don't
need a market halo either but they're
gonna market halo
you don't need to like what's crazy
is that same type of mentality
the super bowl is one of the biggest
dominant things that's ever on tv every
year but they market that [ __ ] like
okay i gotta stop cussing i got stuff
guys all right so like look like
like
that's all i'm saying like just because
something doesn't need a whole lot of
marketing doesn't mean they're not going
to market it you know something like
game pass sure they might not market
every game coming into game pass but
they market game pass and sometimes they
theme it around something
uh so that that's uh you know
question man
christian dirt griggity is starfield
coming out this year is it getting
delayed
i believe it's coming out this year
because they've been talking we ain't
giving you that i didn't i don't believe
son i want a yes
or no
yes i believe starfield is going to drop
this year
okay hustle it has to it's star field
dropping this year is it getting delayed
bro if we get delayed that's the biggest
l yeah it's getting it's dropping this
year and here's the thing i i kind of
hesitate to say this but it's going to
drop this year even if it got a bunch of
bugs in it because they got to keep up
with tradition they did the same thing
with skyrim as i think you educated me
on attic how it came out i think 11 11
11 2011. right
they're going to keep it that they're
going to keep that tradition going and
they're just going to fix each other
along the way and uh the fans they're
fans of it won't care they're going to
be like us but that's that we love it
they're not okay they're angry for real
so yeah that drink drop it's dropping
that day
unless unless unless there's a cyberpunk
situation which i i doubt which i doubt
or fallout 76 situation which i doubt
again
yeah they dropper they definitely drop i
agree awkward
look
if starfield gets delayed out of 2022
oh my god man i'm gonna be hiding
oh i was just about to say i'm not going
on twitter
i'm not going to twitter foreign
look at it from this standpoint you look
at it like and the november thing
attic might not ever show back up on iop
ever
starfield gets delayed man
every week from then on out it's gonna
be like where's addict he's been missing
he's mia missing in action man we don't
know where he went to because i won't
know where i am at that point
it's like my life is done
that'll be bad man
i don't think it's getting delayed
though because
i i feel like it was supposed to come
out last year but the acquisition i feel
like they pushed it back you know maybe
they could have pushed it
pushed it back six months but i think
microsoft's like look we got plenty take
your time we don't need to come this out
uh
it's like i said i don't think microsoft
wants the word bug
fesda anyway in the same sentence as
starfield and i'm glad about that man
like i feel like microsoft is if there's
anything you could say about microsoft
right now is they are giving the
developers the opportunity to make sure
that everything is okay uh psychonauts
take six months man
you know it actually take eight months
you can go go go on vacation to to paris
or something i don't you know then you
you look at wasteland they they gave
them more funding they gave them more
time to to put a lot more bosses and for
the people that haven't played wasteland
there's a lot of stuff in that game that
would not have been in that game if it
wasn't for microsoft same with
psychonauts like what are you saying
if anyone played psychonauts and you
played the bosses that's all microsoft
because all that wasn't in the game yep
i saw that interview with uh adam cecil
he said every boss was not in the game
absolutely hey yo i always say um time
is just as important as you know budget
and
what time is funding
because the longer they develop the more
money they have to spend
oh true true and uh like you just said
xbox is giving these teams that time
that they need and um i think that's
another benefit for having so many teams
under xbox game studios you know because
they're not going to drop 10 exclusives
a year so they're giving those other
teams extra time and that's that's a
great thing
yeah it's just like here's another game
do you guys what do you think the odds
of harry potter being delayed
um
i mean
well i didn't like what i saw for the
record i think but but y'all know that
oh no the audience knows that
um what was the what's the release date
on it's supposed to be october this year
right on my own i thought let's say
october yeah i thought so no i think it
just said
2022 holiday i don't know if it had to
release that i think it might be right
it might not have had a month they might
just say yeah it's called 2022 or
something like that okay
yeah so between september and november
from what i saw even though i didn't
like it you know i just i just i was
about a fan of it it looked fine i don't
think it's going i don't think it's
going to get delayed like uh gotham was
the gotham knights i don't think it's
going to get delayed at all so i think i
think they're fine in that regard
that's what's up man uh you know as far
as anything else
think we can all agree nothing else is
really relevant to that conversation oh
man
hold on there's one other thing relevant
to stuff getting delayed this year
sir no
how are you going to have that
amount
of teenage mutant ninja turtles teenage
mutant ninja turtles shredders revenge
my most dancing you know what you know
i'm gonna do hustle what's up
teenage mutant ninja turtles is getting
delayed to 2023
hey i'm gonna put that in the world man
actually we we we did i i don't know if
we're allowed to say it but i don't care
you know i might be playing i might be
playing teenage mutant ninja turtle here
in the next couple weeks so
against my will uh we gotta fight out
the super chat from flame
i'll give bethesda this if starfield
releases this year it's still released
in a finished state unlike halo infinite
if it doesn't release it's an l
oh yeah i'll give you that man i'm not
gonna really slander too much at this
point
343 has done no
favors to
to uh to halo and they they they need to
get on it man they need to get on it uh
so
you know here's something else we're
going to talk about real quick because
you know we got a little bit sprinkle
some a little bit of you know some
little salt and seasoning in this man
there was some rumors you know obviously
we don't know if these are true
supposedly uh the
the sacred playstation insiders saying
that
yesterday today was mistakes and
tomorrow is when the good stuff's
getting announced oh so you know we'll
see what happens tomorrow most likely uh
i you know what's funny
i set an alarm for 9 00 a.m in case
something happened
i woke up at 9 00 am it was mad
because i just wasted because when i
wake up i'm up
and i figure 9 a.m they're definitely
going to have something by 9am nothing
you know what i saw like
gameplay in-depth
this better gameplay be what they were
talking about
so
the rumor is that sony dropped the bag
and they're they're they're in the
process now buying from software
because of the success of something like
eldon ring uh so you know i want to go
to dirk griggity first on this you know
did you play elden ring
yeah yeah i bought it um
so
playing something like that and i'm sure
even i don't know if you like or not but
even if you didn't like you could play
something like that and see why people
would like a game like that yeah yeah so
you know you're playing this game
do you think something like that's
possible
um shout out to king dave he had said
the other day on on my podcast he said
if they're going to buy from software
now
it's going to be more than it would have
been a couple years ago right because
eldering was a massive success
um i guess it's possible
what do you think
the front software would go for would it
be in the bungee rings 3.6 would it be
more than that i mean i don't know if it
okay so they own elgin ring they own the
dark souls franchise they own the demon
souls no sony owns the demons those
franchise they're in the saccharo
um unless they're going because to me
you don't
you don't buy
from software without the lead over
there
like if i think it's like uh i'm not
even butchering his name we're not doing
that i barely can pronounce english
names when you super chat i'm not gonna
try to pronounce his name
i feel like the only way you keep
from software from software is if you
buy and you keep him
now when you do micro tran when you when
you buy transactions like that and you
buy a company like that it's like todd
howard i'm sure behind closed doors
microsoft is like look we're going to
pay you a lot of money but the
conditions are as you have to save for
this amount of time now i don't know if
todd howard was
thinking about leaving because microsoft
bought them because he's had such a good
relationship with them but i do think
todd howard's on the end of his career
he's probably going to retire in the
next couple years i would say
eldon uh elder scrolls six will be his
last game like i feel like when that's
neither right about the ship or shipped
you'll see him slowly start to pull back
uh and you know it's what's interesting
is
you know we'll get back to that here in
a second you know phil spencer might be
on the very end of his his career too
you know it's kind of interesting who
they might replace him with i know
there's like you know bonnie ross could
not bonnie ross uh you know
sarah you know she could be a potential
i actually think pete heims could be
potential too
uh because i feel like until this
activision thing happened i don't know
now but i felt like when they bought
bethesda they might have wanted to have
a conversation like how about one of you
lead us to show unification you know
what i'm saying but i don't know now
since they own activision it's hard to
say what happened in that general
facility now but anyway back onto the
from software thing hustle
yes sir tell me do you think it's
possible they could buy something like
from software
well before i answer that question i
just want to say um
a really a very famous quote from marlo
stafford from the wife
price of the brick went up y'all
couldn't hear me pounding my desk
because my audio system was good but the
price of the brick went up elder what by
a lot too
yes elden ring did what like 12 million
in like let's say a month and a half
because it's 30. i just realized it was
a march 30th right i joined came out
with february 18th or something like
that yeah bro that joint
man that that that thing going that
thing going and really it'll probably
win game of the year if we are really
being real about it
the joint is still moving in a positive
direction you know shout out to return
on one i don't know jack in the chat
jack and bg they was doing the co-op
thing and that's cool that's cool to
watch but ain't nobody talking about
return though
when nobody talk about what sadly
nobody's talking about that co-op update
or the free dlc that came with it no
matter what's up it's elgin ring l
didn't ring elder ring now if we're
talking about how you're kind of right
though ain't nobody talked about that
return thing
sadly sadly you know no not sadly
sadly for me because i tried that game
i'm trash at it i need some help anywho
look look we talking like this hey man
maybe not maybe you mean you should
stream
that hey well i'm going to use what i'll
tell you this i will set up a date but i
need some help but i'm gonna tell you
though
it'll go for more with the success now
it's gonna go for more than money it'll
probably go for twice as much and
they'll be justifying our purchases see
here's the thing
okay let me finish let me finish now the
boy miyazaki don't like to make singles
of sequels rather so what he'll do is
that he'll move
and you'll have you know you'll have
same gameplay elements but you'll have
like a new pro tag and every other game
that he does man like that that to me is
dope that that to me is like you can go
from like a sakura right
and then you can go to like
what are they called what do they call
this person in the elder in the ring
they might know elden lord
yeah whatever you can go from that to
that and then you know what i mean like
look that that means though but they're
gonna have to pay
so i don't know hey shout out to fame in
them over there level one um they did a
little chat about it yesterday i don't
know where that rumor started but
did y'all see like something about
konami today cause like yeah
every time someone just say microsoft
use the bike notice if you look at my
channel gaming addicts so you know
shameless no you ain't no shameless plug
that's my channel gaming attic you know
so if you look on that channel and you
look at like in acquisition or you
looked up by something indicating
someone buying something you know one
thing you'll notice one thing i haven't
made one video about konami and why i
haven't made one video about konami
ain't nobody want a konami game
castlevania when was the last time we
saw a castlevania game one i can answer
that i can answer that 360 generation
wasn't it
well no no no the last time we saw
cassette cast of my eight games was the
castlevania collection which actually
came out pretty good i don't know the
people who did it i think it was like m2
or something like that
i think they're the ones who will be
doing the um turtles collection as well
there are some some titles to be well
hold on nickelodeon on the ninja turtle
so i gotta slow down on that one but
there are titles to be had with konami
but damn what they used to be that that
boy kojima's gone man like that ain't
what they used to do the only thing that
i could see you buying them for is their
ips you would get castlevania you could
reboot castlevania reboot silent hill
you know i you know it would be crazy if
kojima somehow got his hands on silence
oh man because i actually think he can
make that like look i i might make jokes
saying he belongs in a straight jacket
or this and that but you know because
kojima just that that mind man it's just
like he yeah man
i think he just he belongs in like the
in the the film making industry i think
his visual
like creative brain would be better
served there because a lot of the things
that he wants to do i don't feel like
comes good out in game play
but i feel like like a visual art would
do good there but like as far as from
software
i i think you guys are tripping to think
that that's worth billions of dollars
okay i i think i think it might be worth
like 1.1 bill or something like that but
like here's the thing here's the thing
you're
you're going to have to buy
the dark souls franchises which museok
has already said he ain't he ain't doing
no more with that
so
the value on those is still high but
let's be real here they're not that
expensive
like i i cuz because if he's not gonna
do anything for him like sony really
gonna go in there and be like yo you're
making a dark souls game sure you're
gonna have to buy them but i think you
know they they go up in value if they're
if if they have value right now
like you you buy castlevania it's gonna
have value but is it really being used
now
i i don't think it is like sure i think
some of these things would work good in
tv shows like castlevania you license
that out because it it's better in like
some kind of tv show but then you look
at chakras sacro is a a title that
pretty sure gonna have a sequel so
that's probably worth more than the dark
souls franchise at this point uh you
know they they're i don't know like
i don't know how you value stuff like
that
but to me
[Music]
the value would go up
if it's if it's usable
and i guess you could ve you could value
anything i i could value dark souls a
300 million dollar franchise and that's
how much it would be worth but it's only
willing to pay that for that franchise i
don't think they would
uh you know
eldon ring probably going to be a few
hundred million franchise um
sony willing to pay that i don't know
now that the question is is can you
convince because without miyuzaki
from software i don't feel like it's
gonna hit as much now i'm not saying
that the rest of the studio isn't
talented it's a very talented studio but
without that individual there you could
tell the games that he worked on the
games he didn't work on you know he
worked on uh to my knowledge he worked
on dark souls 1 but didn't work on two
you can tell the quality between those
two
uh so
to me how are you going to convince him
to work on his games he says he's not
going to work on
you know i mean hey look hold on money
talk though dawg like listen listen
hello maybe but because of eldon ring
yeah
okay that's what i'm saying you want to
pay absolutely you got to pay but be hey
here's my thing because of eldon ring
can you really give this individual
enough money
like to shut up
like because now he knows that he could
take this elder ring franchise that so
12 million units in two days no two
weeks and he could be like you ain't
gonna give me what i expect i could go
somewhere else and make just as much
he could probably sell now with you guys
talking
microsoft probably would give him that
much money for it
because they
they they will see that i'm not saying
his stuff isn't worth that i'm saying
from a gaming standpoint his stuff isn't
worth that elder rings valuable checkers
value dark souls valuable demon souls is
valuable but is it valuable in today's
industry some of it is and some of it
isn't
yes yes and cannot explain why can i
explain why
souls ain't this souls genre ain't niche
no more look i got a theory that it
started with bloodborne because a lot of
people on ps4 was playing that joint b
not me though not me because that just
wasn't my thing
that soul genre if people ain't scared
of that joint no more dog look i don't
be i beat my agree
i beat it with the help of an npc it's
on my channel y'all go check that out
pardon my language of course
i went off when i did that like that
that feeling is kind of like euphoric
like the first time you do that and it's
like oh you figured out i don't care if
it's a tutorial boss than that everybody
shut the hell up look
it's like a you get a little rush behind
that it's like it is like playing the
game on the hardest difficulty but you
get a little rush behind that and it's
like
like and a lot of people are doing this
and i i want to say i read a report i
think it was john bomb it might have
been um
a friend of the show um
jeff
not gerschmann jeff grubb it might have
been him who put that out on adventure
beat was like 70 percent of like people
who got the game
beat my greek so that's i feel good
about that so i'm a part of that 70 but
i remember that i remember that floating
around too so that yo this though
everybody like this though
well most most of the people like this i
saw iop and i saw i think it was king
who was like a lot of people bought it
and never turned it
i i can't roll like that i'm not rolling
no you know but a lot of people are
buying this they they do owe blood board
too which sony owns bloodborne so they
won't have to pay for that
so like you know i it's like like
someone said eldon ring is grossing in a
billion dollars i get that not saying
that that i literally said that would
probably be the most profitable
franchise
all i'm saying is you could ask for
something that doesn't mean you're going
to get it
and you know do you think that you know
if insomniac was like we ain't selling
for less than a billion dollars you
think sony would have said yeah
sure
let me write you a check for a billion
dollars like no it's whatever
is in the realms of possibility for that
publisher and i'm not saying sony's is a
poor company by no means am i saying
that but they do have less to spend than
something like microsoft
and especially something like that makes
it even harder because now from
software's like we hot right now i go to
anyone i want if i want to sell what are
you going to do to make this more sweet
than microsoft couldn't do
they've worked with activision before
that activision can't do like everyone
wants to buy from software right now
i've been told
firsthand everyone is talking to this
company
and
miyazaki might not even sell because as
you go someone pointed
eldon ring is in a very very successful
game there's very few games that done
with eldon ring done shut the internet
up
i was like i said earlier i was being
told by youtubers that know what they're
doing that's got a huge following
yo i i don't make a video right now if
it's not elderly ring just take a break
like this
man
so see
see the thing with eldering
like you guys said it's such a success
right now
they just sell like 10 million on on
steam alone
i don't know
that i'm not sure of but i know i saw
many concurrent players on this thing
like i remember i saw that i said oh god
man that's crazy see the thing is uh
didn't sony um have a incentive they was
like 150 million just for the employees
at bungie
yeah see
that's what a lot of people don't
realize too you're not only paying for
the company you're paying for the
retention bonuses to keep these
individuals because if you buy from
software and everybody leaves then you
literally just bought an empty shelf
absolutely absolutely so i mean and
you're gonna have from some more you're
gonna have to probably hand miyazaki
probably 500 million by itself to make
him stay like it's just like look like
at the end of the day i'm not talented
i'm not saying that this company and
then let's be real here people saying
that miyuzaki wouldn't sell money
changes that
if you offer someone enough money
miyazaki's been doing this for a long
time
you offer him enough money if he's like
i made a game that might be considered
one of the greatest games ever made
he might see that is
it's time to retire
like for all you know
he myself from software make one more
game under sony's brand and then retire
with a big
big big big bag
absolutely
so
let's talk about what
let me say this before you go so this is
supposed to be announced tomorrow or
there's some big news period is supposed
to be announced in the morning i don't
know man you know how these people are
they keep changing their mind first it
was yesterday then it was the day now
it's tomorrow
like
well i just say i saw greg miller and a
lot of people in our community is kind
of responding to that um he had tweeted
out something hey i pushed px out xo i
love whatever you say you push this
podcast as opposed i think they recorded
today or they released it today said i
was gonna do it on thursdays so that
kind of led people to believe a lot of
things and okay hey look i'll just say
this man you know if don't nothing
happen there greg you might wanna stop
the internet for a little bit because
they they're gonna be on you they're
gonna get them but yeah they are yeah
they don't get them we'll see then i
guess
i guess greg miller is kind of a person
that knows people so i you know
i guess maybe we should listen but we'll
see
well you know maybe it was the
playstation plus he delayed his podcast
for
oh yeah smooth uh we're about to talk
about these xbox mpds you want to jump
in here real quick for this topic you
can i know you got to buy it guys at
like 8 39 i can't remember when planet
xbox goes live but uh you could jump in
here if you want talk about these xbox
npd's just uh put something in the chat
if you want to let's talk about xbox one
and mpds all right now
it's kind of
for the past couple weeks and i know vg
charts a lot of people don't really
consider a lot of vg charts like like
standard or any kind of like relevancy
whatsoever but it is interesting to see
a console
brand known as xbox to come off probably
one of the worst l's they've ever had in
the gaming industry known as the xbox
one generation
and they're starting this generation
with it so close
like didn't they do like in the just in
the states
place xbox is only like not even a
million behind them
in just the states like that is insane
if you think about it like the fact that
playstation 4 was the most popping thing
since like justin beaver
and you mean to tell me
that
that brand that did all of that damage
to the xbox generation was able to
rehabilitate itself and come out at the
beginning of the series generation and
be able to not necessarily stand toe to
toe now i do see some like screenshots
on twitter saying that they won
worldwide a couple weeks i don't know if
that's true we're not gonna go that far
okay but you know i'm gonna go that far
they won a couple weeks worldwide so you
know
you know regardless if they won a couple
weeks worldwide it's interesting it is
because i see uk numbers going up now
people
now i want to go to hustle first because
i hear this a lot hustle
people say but add it
playstation can make more uh does it
can't make it as many units as xbox
hustle do you think that is a a valid
criticism to what's going on
yes if if it's true mute this mic
now regardless here's the thing now
regardless of who's buying these systems
if xbox is pushing on more of them and
they have the ability to push out more
regardless if people got them or well
scott was just getting them
xbox if they are selling more like that
that whole number in america i had no
idea about so that that was like
shocking to hear um
oh hold on one second hold on one second
hey go to dirk go to dirt
what about you dirt now let's
let's talk about how do you feel about
that that that
example that people say they they like
they're like dirt griggity the reason
they do it is because they can make more
units and you know what they they love
doing dirt they love blaming it on the
series s
but then the same people say the series
s don't sell
right the same people see okay i want to
say this
i
i like to use an analogy of you know
sports right say you know my favorite
sports teams make the championship their
opponent best player gets injured
we win the championship
i don't give a damn that he's injured
we're still going to celebrate our
championship win my point in saying that
is uh it's not xbox fought sony couldn't
produce enough consoles
it's not xbox thought that
maybe the ps5 is over engineered i don't
know
xbox made a strategy with the xbox
series s
they're they're able to develop more
of
of that console and they're putting it
out there and people are buying it
people are buying it so
if this is true which is i mean because
people say bt charts is not accurate but
sometimes they're in the right ballpark
yeah i feel like
you know first off no one's accurate i i
can't you can't make me feel believed
that someone out there has the exact
number
and i would say it's probably in the
thousands that they're not accurate
they got estimations that they put
together and act like his fault is like
accurate information like they got ball
game parks now sometimes vg charts is a
little bit more unaccurate than the rest
but i don't think it's like some drastic
number
right i agree with you i agree with you
so i think this just shows um at the end
of the day the strategy that xbox
implemented is working a little bit
better the two console strategy um is
working than the playstation strategy
but it is what it is i mean there are
some chip shortages everywhere like i'm
i'm supposed to get a new vehicle but
it's taking forever to produce because
of this these chip shortages um but i
will say this that
you guys said in our iron lord's podcast
cognito said it king david said it
every generation is different every
generation is different we can't just go
by well the ps4 dominated so they're
automatically going to dominate the next
generation back when the ps2 days the
ps2 sold 155 million consoles
the ps3 was revealed people wasn't
feeling it
no we don't want it the xbox 360 was
loved
even do even throughout the red rings of
death people still love the 360. we
forgave them
well the xbox one people said well we're
not feeling it
so every generation is different man so
um to see the xbox is actually
selling well you mentioned uh addict
like in america they're really close in
the
under a million to the ps5 so i think
that's incredible and it is what it is
yeah so uh hustle i see you back uh you
know do you want to comment more on all
this
um well uh when you mention that number
uh the u.s numbers only i was a little
surprised by that um and i want you to
repeat the question for me because i had
to run outside i moved my car and that
was the whole thing my fault my barrier
so pretty much you know my question to
you is do you think that
these
the cells of the xbox series s and x
do you think that
you know
it do first off do you think it's fair
that we compare two different skews of a
console to one skew as the playstation
or you think that's like a slippery
slope
it's a bit of a slippery slope because
playstation they offer a 500 version
which is the physical version and the
400 version which is the digital version
granted it's the same thing aside from
the disk drive
but that it doesn't matter like
it don't matter like playstation they
need they need to cut that digital joint
to 300 to match microsoft they feel like
if they feel like that's a problem if
you feel like that's a problem then you
you probably smash them all the way
around and that way you're gonna have a
better product at the same price but
nah man i'm i'm surprised to see
microsoft even
like bounce back i know dirk as i was
coming back in
you were mentioned like the 360 era like
that was almost like a wrap for them
after that that was a billion dollar
problem and it was
yeah steve obama had to sign that check
he had to go just go ahead and do it
that was the thing and i didn't know if
xbox was going to be able to bounce back
and then we saw what happened last
generation so
so to see xbox doing what they're doing
now like that's brand new uh
rehabilitation yo shout out the first
plan sending everybody over there that
that
nope i no no none of us saw that coming
i didn't well i know xbox cam but i
didn't think that they was going to be
able to bounce back now they buying all
the studios and yeah and i do want to
mention this and i'm not sure if either
one of you all mentioned it
those sales are like up in my honest
opinion just because of like the
the media reaction like microsoft 80
good guys right now man oh xbox let's
just say somebody so xbox they're the
good guys right now man i got a little
bit of the media dollars as you were i
got a little bit of pushback for you
guys all right so let's
let's talk about
the past couple months i think we can
all agree
that the past couple months
sony's had a decent to good month they
had horizon coming out they had um
uh i think the show came out recently
they had no no no the show didn't come
out
no it comes out this month but no next
month i don't keep track of none of that
stuff so that's why you don't see i
don't care about baseball they had sifu
come out i feel like i'm missing
something something else came out
it is oh babylon's fall babylon oh oh
come on
hey come on i'm sorry brother we still
gotta say it it's still a game so they
had babylon's fall come out
what is xbox came out
xbox has been driving man i can't
imagine somebody had no like
no small games but so how is xbox
winning these months with no games
game pass game passing let me you know
not that this one person oh gt7 grand
triple seven right there it is
but but i want to say not that not that
there's one person who i know in real
life who actually approached me today
about this a good friend of mine who a
colleague of mine who i worked with she
said she brought her husband at xbox i
said what you're getting a serious ass
or series x and she said she didn't know
the difference i said i said is it a
white box or a black box she said oh she
said it's a white box i said oh okay so
you got in series s so because he plays
like call of duty and stuff like that
and she was
i said no no i'm sorry go ahead oh no
you still you started nah so she was
just asking me she was like well she's
like you know she cause i told her about
the podcast and everything she's like oh
when you do the gaming thing you know
what game should i buy on xbox i said
well what games do you like so addict
you love her if she was single she's
like she like kingdom hearts i'm like i
said uh
so so kingdom hearts so since you're
missing kingdom hearts and she doesn't
like first-person games she likes
third-person games so i kind of
explained that different story too how
you can you know a third person you see
a character and first person you just
see like the hands and or the gun or
whatever so i explained that to it so
she was like oh no i like to see my
character the second third
so i was telling her about she said well
what game should i get for the xbox i
said you know what
i said i can't really answer that i said
giving us a give and get taste i said i
would say get game pass i said they have
a a wide variety of like everything i
said they got games that you don't even
know that you like yet she kind of
laughed look what that mean i was like
it's your new favorite game all up in
that one service she said well how much
is the service man microsoft hey you
know what
phil you got to pay me you want to pay
i'm up here at work by the way putting
in work for y'all you got to pay me sir
anyhow nah like i was just having a good
game pass and you know it's no 10 15
bucks
i have no problem putting his uh paypal
in the chat just saying like hey that's
fact
you like to drop off the miyazaki money
right now you want me to boy if they pay
and i swear to god
that's a great point man there's a great
point you know what game pass i think
is huge for xbox at the moment and also
let's be honest fellas uh sometimes
people
you know like we've been talking about
the activision blizzard thing for a few
months now
that was a huge announcement
i have a friend that called me he's a
casual
this guy plays madden 2k and call of
duty that's the only three games he
plays every year
he called me because you know i'm the
video game guy that people call when
they want to ask somebody something
right hey dirk
the the xbox buying call of duty you
know like he ain't say activists he
ain't nobody activists he just heard no
call of duty
i said yeah brother they um
yeah
it's not official yet but yeah that's
what they're about to do and he said
does that mean no because he has game
pass
even though he doesn't play it but he
still has it he said does that mean
they're about to
put it in game pass i said when it's
official yeah
and he was like oh man that's what i'm
talking about so
i think that was some huge news and it
actually hit casuals because call of
duty is such a huge game for casuals and
uh man
that was pretty big
and plus like word of mouth is going
around like yo man you play game pass
you know xbox has this that has that so
it's pretty big stuff man yeah i
definitely hear you on that one man so
you know
all i have to say about like the the
mpd's
it doesn't surprise me that they're
they're doing well uh you know
it is interesting that it's so close
because i would have thought that it
would have took time to start building
momentum
i agree and i felt like it would be when
these games start coming out like the
fables the vows
but it doesn't seem like it's taking
that long like and if they're starting
to gain this momentum without those
games what's going to happen when those
games drop oh hey addict that's a great
point man that's a great point it's
funny because
it just it just happens this way like
you made a great point i was expecting
even me as a die-hard xbox guy i was
expecting it to take a little bit longer
for them to kind of gain some momentum
and the first half of this year has been
a little dry but no it's no it is what
it is
but this drive is different than 2017's
right right because
when in like 2017 we knew nothing that
was on the way it was thirsty
no no no no no you have a role model now
now like you know i'm not i'm still
thirsty but at least i've already
ordered the drinks and they commented
and they're coming exactly i ordered the
pizza i'm hungry i ordered the pizza
it's like i got it but it's on his way
the pizza man taking too long though man
he gotta get here
you know we got a ten dollar super trip
from don utaku the two consoles play all
the same games so of course they count
together plus sony still could win with
dollar sales while selling less consoles
it's not a ps4 and a vita i i vids i
don't know what he means maybe vita
assume i don't know daughter taku i'm
i'm hoping that's what you meant fitz
we're going to go with this yeah yeah
i guess you're trying to say like once
the console wants a handheld maybe
they're still both the same i don't know
console pretty much i don't know but you
know
i think that we're gonna see a bigger
shift now
i've always been one of those people
that if sony doesn't
start building
a foundation to combat game pass at its
height
i don't think they're going to be able
to do it while it's there
uh it's the same thing we said last
generation in the middle of last
generation
microsoft at the beginning had a certain
amount of time to get their stuff
together before sony started shooting
stuff out they didn't
they lost all the whole generation
because of it and i'm not a lot of mines
here and i'm not saying that
it's over for playstation because they
have
they have some very successful brands
but it's like i've said on iop over and
over again you can have as many games as
you want that's good people are going to
go where they feel like they're getting
more consistent games they're still
going to buy your platform
i got this weightlifting ps5 over here
you know they're still going to buy that
but it's going to be their secondary
console now it's not going to be their
first when you lose that secondary
platform you lose where your friends are
you lose because people are shifting
where their friends are if you're not on
the platform where your friends are
you're on another platform where your
friends are that's what they're in
jeopardy here is to be coming the
playstation box that they play
playstation exclusives and
all i'm saying man is sony got a little
bit they got a couple probably another
year and a half to two years to really
try to find you know they're obviously
they're doing something they're buying
studios they're trying to accommodate
for this mountain of games it's about to
hit them
but
the question is can they successfully
do that while keeping stuff like
bungie's destiny off the competitor
platform if they brawn [ __ ] if they buy
from software is that gonna be off the
competing platform we don't know because
i would have normally said yo
there's no way
it ever happens where you see a game
that a studio that sony buys on a
competing platform but we saw it we're
seeing it now with bungie they bought
bungie and they've said that they're
that nothing's changing now obviously i
don't believe that i got to see it
before i believe it but i gotta go off
with the telling me currently which is
nothing's going to change there so if
they're doing stuff like that and
they're holding punches together because
that was probably one of the caveats to
us buying you so we're not going to mess
we're not going to
change the way you do stuff that's
probably one of the caveats we don't
know what's going to happen there but
we're going to talk about the main event
of the evening
oh boy
for those of you that's been sitting
hold up
for those of you that's been sitting
under a rock man
playstation plus got a rebrand
on there it is now
a playstation now has a rebrand it's not
playstation plus essential playstation
plus essential what what's what's the
other one playstation extra
playstation plus essential extra and
playstation plus
premium premium okay so first off
let's talk about
what these happen we're going to go over
everything and then we're going to get
the opinions of the panel because i feel
like that's good i'm going to do it the
way i do my videos man all right so
first off there's the playstation plus
essential i have no clue why they named
it this should be named bronze i don't
know why but we're gonna we're gonna go
with a whack name
hey wait wait wait wait before you go on
it should have been named after that
trophy system hey i wouldn't even think
all right yeah yeah
yeah that would have made a lot more
sense yeah brian silver
man i don't know bronze gold yeah
brought seven gold or could have been i
mean yeah yeah my fault go ahead yeah
all right so
provides the same benefits that
playstation plus members are getting
today
such as
two monthly downloadable games which if
i remember correctly they keep lowering
that number it used to be like
playstation three games playstation vita
games
so
they've took
more from you than less this is just
another uh advancement at that uh at
that center
exclusive discounts
they got decent discounts over there
their flag shows are pretty on point so
i can't say not about that it is worth
it just for those discounts
cloud storage for saved games explain to
me why they still charging for that
that's a very good question that's uh
why are they charging for that online
multiplayer access you know what would
be the craziest response to this from
microsoft them dropping the paywall for
again for online gaming
like you could still have the uh you
know the parties and stuff be blocked
behind uh you know xbox live but when it
comes to
the online infrastructure drop that but
obviously you know i think that's gonna
happen eventually just not now all right
so first off let's there's nothing
really to talk about this is just this
is literally what you're paying for
right now uh i will say that their their
monthly games are usually pretty good
they're not like play xbox is is god
awful i don't i don't know why they keep
doing it they charge you money for
for uh
uh xbox gold and then they give you some
of the worst games with gold that you
could possibly think of
so now let's let's talk about the
playstation plus
extra
extra kind of one
i would have preferred that to be called
ultra before
extra like playstation plus ultra and
then they have like the street fighter
dude say ultra like i don't know it just
okay so
provides all the benefits from the
essential tiers so you're getting
everything that you got from what you've
been currently paying for
up until this point you can add up to a
catalog up to 400 of the most enjoyable
ps4 and ps5 games including blockbuster
hits from our playstation studio catalog
and third party partners games of the
extra tier are downloadable
for play
and then that is
15.99 so that's the price of xbox live
ultimate
ultimate
we got more yes we have more there's
something above
xbox live ultimate xbox game pass
ultimate and i'm sure people in the
chats like addict it's got to be amazing
it's more money it's more money than the
ultimate
games as a service tier you know what
bring it down we're going to break it
down dirt
break it down so we got we got the
playstation plus
premium
yes provides all the benefits from the
essential and extra team
adds up to
340 additional games including
ps3 games available through cloud
streaming wow
a catalog of beloved classic games
available in both streaming and download
options from the original playstation
ps2
and psp generations
offers cloud streaming access to the
original playstation ps2 psp ps4 games
offered in the extra and premium tiers
and markets
so let's let's i'm gonna talk about that
for five seconds so
their
little selling point for this one is
offering you the games from previous
tiers just you could stream them
can we keep going we're gonna kick off
where playstation now is currently
available
customers can stream games using the ps4
and ps5 consoles
and pc
tied limited game trials will also be
available in this tier so customers
could try games before they buy oh demos
demos they charge you demos so guess
what griggity guess what grady what's up
my brother it is on the highest one they
have so
one could say they're charging you three
dollars just to try demos i don't know
but
the united how much it's going to cost
you for this isn't 15
it isn't 16
hell it's not even 17
eighteen dollars
monthly
eighteen dollars
all right all right so let let's let's
let's let's get dirt ger giddy what
what is your opinion on the amazing
surface that i just read
word for word
okay
okay
so let's break this down
playstation plus is uh
extensional uh
essential i'm sorry
it's pretty much the playstation plus
they have now right
so
let's just skip extra i don't know why
they even have extra they should have
the playstation plus and they should
have premium
premium
now the game demos wow is behind the
paywall
um
backwards compatibility right that's
behind the paywall also
um and this and the ps3 is streaming
only correct
but some of the ps1 and ps2 games you
you can download some of them and that's
probably just going to be the games that
you could download for the ps2 uh i mean
for the ps3 i don't know
i'm not 100 sure on stuff like that but
i would say it's the games that they
naturally have on the store already
okay so let me say this um
with this service i see people saying
it's not a game pass competitor right
don't get me straight inside the game
right of course it's not but i'm trying
to figure out
why are they really doing this
i know they're combining ps now and ps
plus together
um but what's the purpose of this
service um i'm just kind of you know
trying to figure it out now xbox game
pass benefits you know gamers this i
mean this does have games and of course
demos are cool
well
i don't want to pay for demos
i heard somebody say yeah access had had
10 hours try to have 10 hour trials
right
and it was 30 a year
now
maybe because some of playstation games
are single-player games they can't
really have 10-hour trials for obvious
reasons right so i'm still trying to
figure out
what is the purpose of this
um service
because this doesn't seem like it's
really
it will move the needle in my opinion um
if you had games day and date i can
definitely understand that um i
understand why sony is not doing day and
date but
i just don't understand the the purpose
to have this service people say
game pass is not a threat if if game
pass is not a threat then why is sony
doing something like this they say it's
not a competitor but i just don't
understand this can someone help me out
with that
you know what i can i can't help you out
durger y'all hustle wants to go get his
dogs real quick he'll be back now okay
this is what i filmed maybe you know
house is usually here for me to do this
but today we're going to do with dirk
ergetti
dirt tell me if i'm tripping
okay
when you look at those two tiers man you
look at that essential no it's not
essential central's playstation plus
down you got that extra tier and that
premium tier
does it not seem like they split
gang uh playstation now into two
different tiers and they're charging you
more money than the original service
offered
that's a that's exactly what it seems
like because so you're not tripping it's
like
to me
all you would have had to do you mean
you could have made it fifteen dollars
because i think i think xbox is paid the
way to make two different tiers of of a
platform now obviously i think they can
still do three but you have to have
value in three but i don't see value in
three i i don't see it either yeah i
don't see the value
i just don't
um
i don't know man
i don't know i'm not trying to be that
xbox fan
or like people call me xbox fanboy
that's hating on playstation i'm just
trying to figure this out
um and then i heard they said they're
not really trying to
i don't know i'm paraphrasing here but
didn't they say something about their
their focus is not on adding new
subscribers or something this
i don't know man i just don't get it
what's the purpose to do this if you're
not trying to add new subscribers if
you're not trying to grow your
subscription
what is going to make a playstation fan
that's not a fanboy go to this service
because backwards compatible games are
great like i recently finished are you
going to pay 15 for backwards yeah see
that's my exact point see but i recently
went back and finished max payne one and
two
i already had the original xbox version
of max payne too
put i put the disc in it just worked i
didn't have max payne one but i bought
it was like five dollars or something
and not only that
when i played those games
the graphics was like the resolution was
like i don't know if it was 4k but the
resolution was pretty great so it was
some type of enhancement now xbox they
enhance the backwards compatible games
and if you have those games it just
works
so now you want us to pay a fee for
backwards compatible games and if their
ps3 is streaming only
and there's no enhancement
i just don't i just don't get it now
you know what i think it is i think
there's multiple layers to this i think
one layer
they got tired of being the laughing
stalk when it comes to playstation now
so if you combine
those horrible numbers
with playstation plus
you naturally get more numbers than your
competitor
you know because now it's not oh it's 2
million to 25 million now technically
playstation now can uh merge but
playstation plus has more subscribers
than than game pass so i think
i think uh you know
visually it like that's what i'm looking
for
like narrative wise they had to do it i
feel like that they still think there is
a chance
that this game pass thing blows up in
their face like they know that microsoft
has something but they're unsure what
it's going to do in the long run so i
think they're trying to like
stop from
over extending as long as possible but
anyway you know we got 278 people in
here man hit that like button if you
guys let's get that above 150 likes
before the end of the podcast i
appreciate it but anyway
you know back to this
i feel like there's a chance that they
know
the industry is going to shift left
they don't know how left but they know
it's going to shift left
and it's already starting to shift left
i think
if you look at that 18 tier
it doesn't make sense
this doesn't yeah you could have put all
of that stuff into the second tier and
been fine
right so i'm looking at that i'm like
why make it
unless
they feel like if things go left they're
going to need something
to throw their games into
right
and
let's say a year and a half two years
comes from now
and
they're starting to lose market share
because game pass got fable coming out
perfect dark coming out well maybe not
perfect talk but yeah you got all these
games you got all these games hitting
hellblade avowed and
they're hitting game pass every couple
months
and then you see the markets because the
market's already shifting
but it's not drastically now we said
earlier in the podcast when you get
all these games coming out in a matter
of a certain amount of time that's when
you're going to see a lot more of the
shift
so i think sony's they're looking
they're looking at they're like
if this shift is bigger than we think
it's going to be
we're going to hit the red button and
drop all our games in that 18 tier
absolutely because you heard like jim
ryan said
things can change right he said things
can't change with that interview with
christopher dreams
that's that's my way of i mean in my
eyes he's just saying never say never
but you're absolutely right adam because
sony's not stupid
um they've seen companies like
blockbuster or like blackberry not
really
stick with the the times the industry is
evolving and they they've noticed it
that's why they're doing games as a
service now they say oh you know what
these great single-player games that we
make uh
you know they're not that
that beneficial they know they
they know they got legs and they can
sprint fast but they know that
they don't got no wind in them
all right they know they're going to
start slowly sprinting and before you
know they're not sprinting anymore
absolutely so yeah so they gotta uh they
they have to make a decision i mean
what you just said i think is is a great
point they're getting prepared for just
in case right if game pass continues to
flourish
which is definitely possible especially
once the activision blizzard deal is
finalized but every single call of duty
diablo and every activism blizzard game
and if they do make future exclusives
over there which i'm sure they will add
division blizzard every but there's a
game like you mentioned all the other
xbox game studio titles
they're going to have
shout out to my boy pong so he said
avalanche
of content xbox will
and playstation they're they're going to
notice that and like you said worse
comes to worse they might you know what
if they i'm i'm telling you right if
they put their games day and day
eventually
i'm going to subscribe immediately
immediately
you know because it benefits me
and it's by and it's and it's my wallet
it's not anybody else's wallet so i
don't care what anybody else would think
about my money and i i think that
the only reason i'm really pushing that
18 dollar tier is because if you look at
that tier
none of that makes sense
i don't feel like sony
realistically thinks that they can sell
a high tier like that for just streaming
pretty much
and just show some demos like that
that's that's what i'm looking at and
you know i feel like they don't want to
just make two tiers
because they they feel like if they did
put their games into service they want
it higher than fifteen dollars
so that that you put that eighteen
dollars you take the l with that tier
because it's a tier system it's not
gonna matter if people don't
do to the highest one
you know hula is a successful
subscription service to a point and
there's a lot of people that don't
subscribe to the no ads thing doesn't
mean it's not successful
right
let me get these super chats real quick
okay we got a two dollar super draft
from pixel bit g bingo addict this is a
sony fudge and it's an l
i don't know what the fudge part is but
we'll keep going we gotta fight out this
picture from andrew courtney
game pass for me has been more
beneficial for discovering games and
experiences i've never would have sought
on my own
love the indies they promote and what's
funny is gabe has floors because
he had mr super chat from flame
up flame
oh you want me really yeah that's fine
flame with the five dollars the three
tiers of playstation plus is for the
amount of people who actually wanted
this rebrand all hell jim clown shoes
ryan
wow
messy man messy this that's that's that
that that's flame for you man uh you
know
i will say that
you know a lot of these super chats
they're pretty they're they're spot on
we're gonna have to see exactly what
happens when the actual
service comes out you know we don't we
don't know 100 of what they're going to
do yet
um
i'm curious about the game trials like
what's the time limit you know i'm
saying like i'm just curious about that
will it be you know like 30 minute time
limit or
what well i will be all all first party
games or just uh
some like some chosen few you know i
don't know i'm curious about that also
yeah so i mean at the end of the day you
know what's interesting i'm looking at
um
i'm looking
at twitter right now
and i think we're about to get some bad
news from undead labs
uh did you see this
yeah earlier uh yeah yeah they
interviewed um
jeff strange like the guy that
started the studio oh apparently it's
the article that he's referring to he's
not out yet
he said that
kutaku is publishing an article on
undead labs today here are my thoughts
and he said he he messaged and it was 15
minutes ago and said kutaku notified me
by email yesterday evening that they
were planning to publish today no
earlier than noon
uh eastern as of 7 p.m eastern this
evening they have not yet published the
article
so
i'm kind of i got some i got some
connects over there i might i might i
might take a stab see if i can find
something over there a lot of my people
oh no i thought i was about a public he
published something in like okay refer
like talking to them about it
i guess but they haven't
actually oh my gosh man undead labs i
can't go into the stuff i know about
that but
i can tell you right now whatever
they're they're publishing is not going
to be good it's not going to be
but oh yes
i love i actually like state of decay 2
like it wasn't a high quality game but i
actually enjoyed the game so hustle
yes hustling yes
how do you feel
about these
new
tiers of playstation plus you got the
playstation plus essential playstation
plus extra and playstation plus
premium how you feel about it okay
all right
playstation essential
is good that is cool for what it is
playstation
you know what's cool
i'm going i'm going straight to the
premium the premium is god-awful you got
demos behind the paywall now now i'm
going to take y'all all the way back to
1994. playstation was known or
infamously known especially if you grew
up poor for what heaven demo what demo
disc so now they're going to challenge
you to play demos dog i don't care what
it's for and i don't care what it's for
either first of all when y'all play them
demos like that they add to development
time so don't get too too hyped up off
of it if they got uncharted five over
there and you could you get to play it
early yeah that's cool you get to play
it earlier we're just gonna add more
time to have that actual game come out
um
this is not a competitor the game pass
i'm sure y'all said that
i didn't have to be here for that
my heart racing dog i was chasing both
of them damn dogs up the street my fault
oh man yeah i bro i'm tired i'm out of
shape sir i am really out of shape look
having like this is not a direct
competitor to the game pass and i'll
tell you why
i saw the ps3 games you can only stream
those you couldn't download those for
whatever reason i don't know if it has
anything to do with like that cell
architecture yeah but i read our article
at least part of me i saw an article i
want to say it was from gamestop or was
it from game informer i can't remember
game spot or gaming form i can't
remember which
but yo the ps5 is strong enough to
emulate the ps3 stuff and it is by the
way it really is they can develop a good
software emulator and like really
go run that if they really want to um
this is a shame man it's a shame and i
don't really like how they robbing their
fans they pretty much got got the gun up
on them and said don't move they tell
them don't move like they're robbing
them they're robbing them blindness
that's not right man
look this will never be a direct
competitor the game pass why
because the new games don't come out day
one like the biggest hook at least for
me as far as game pass is concerned and
the price their pricing chair is kind of
crazy too you got to offer me everything
that xbox is offering me if you want to
charge me just as much as they do uh i
think it's a i start us off for the
ultimate one uh premium one that's 120
per year that's what i paid with game
pass on pc now my thing with game pass
on pc is i'll stop paying for that
however
however
the second they they put everything in
tandem with one another man kyle had
this conversation the second they put
everything and you know everything will
mirror what's on the console version and
the pc version then i'm cool with paying
ten dollars a month i would probably
even pay a little bit more but i was
looking at the prices right and i really
hate how they do this they really want
to lock you in for the one year like
i'm looking at the joint it's um
it's eighteen dollars a month
it's fifty dollars quarterly and a
hundred and twenty dollars yearly you
know you you pay more
over the course if you just pay for a
monthly like the month by month you're
gonna end up paying a lot more like
right it's not and if you play it
quarterly you gonna pay 150 a year
that's not or a little bit more than
that that's not cool man
that's not cool what's up let's go ahead
and i do have this
this
this thing that igm posted all right
it's like a little little chart um i'm
gonna send you guys the link
uh to
to the chat thing
and i want you guys to look at this real
quick and you know i'm gonna leave it up
for give you guys about a minute about a
minute to look at this and tell me
if you see anything
not
not like kind of like out of the
ordinary on here so give me a second
tell me if you guys see anything out of
the ordinary
all right um
i see it immediately
that's the ordinary yeah you see
anything
that's out of the ordinary that should
be here
just keep looking
okay
i see something about price per year
that kind of it's my attention but i
want to make sure before i mention that
no
you know until someone says something
i give you guys a couple more seconds
something that's out of the ordinary
out of the ordinary let me see
you some of the backwards compatibility
thing access to all the games no no
something that that that that's
that's weird just just keep looking like
oh sir sir come on i'm i'm horrible at
this stuff i'll hello
oh no you some of the cloud saves no
i see that okay i'll give you i'll give
you i'll give you a stand out to me it's
something that should be there's a snot
there
oh family plans no no oh so
fat and cracking just said at the chat
my boy found him crying what do you say
they don't have oh day and date i said
that earlier they don't have
ign
didn't put in this thing
the most oh what they was missing oh my
fault
yeah i was looking at the chart like
everything day in day you're absolutely
right yeah you know i saw this earlier
yeah you're right they don't have day
and day they didn't put the biggest
advantage of xbox game pads on this list
it's chart that's the main reason why i
got it
if you think about it
like look i got friends over that ign
but
it's like come on guys
how do you forget the the literally
the most important feature in this like
whoever made this l
like l right or automatically
and and i'm not saying that you know
anyone's a bad person or anything like
that all i'm just saying man like
you're supposed to be a journalist you
know what i'm saying like
oh
my god can y'all hear us yeah you can
hear me now i apologize for that when i
was switching it back for some reason it
it muted the stream
uh podcast isn't down but we're not down
yeah it was just uh it was human error
man it's human error
all right so look that's all i have to
say about that like you know be a little
bit better on that ign like as far as
as far as
this new
playstation plus thing it's i i do think
it's competition for for game pass it's
just not very good competition uh you
know it's a subscription service that's
offering you
uh titles and you know i do think if you
only have a playstation it is worthy of
getting
you know if you only have a playstation
but you know if you're looking for an
xbox series x or an s or a ps5
i'm sorry like maybe the best choice for
you would be a w at xbox because i feel
like you get more bang for your buck uh
you know i feel like it's a more variety
of stream uh games uh not streamer but a
variety of games
uh we got a ten dollar super chat from
dawn otaku
saying this service doesn't compete with
xbox game pass is like saying the worst
team in the nba isn't competing with the
best team just because it's trash
doesn't mean they didn't build this to
compete completely
let me let me respond to that let me
respond to that that's like
burger king going to competition with
the big mac right over there at
mcdonald's with no whopper stop playing
though like the biggest thing on that is
the day one games it says it says we're
glitching
huh
yeah it seems like youtube's having
issues
oh oh that sucks no i ign came through
with the oh yeah i was talking y'all was
talking that were you
i mean i wasn't really talking mess it
was just bringing up while you put the
cake
is it great
is it back up uh
hold on let me see
i think we are
oh
i don't know
all right it says excellent connection
now okay are we good okay no you're good
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
close this in like 15 minutes 10 minutes
before they shut my ass down again i
don't know what's going on you know i'm
not going to go and say like ign is
doing it obviously that was a joke
you're joking yeah okay like don't be
going out there saying ign sniping the
attic showdown look i wasn't even saying
anything bad about them i was just
saying you know
come on the best service best feature of
the services and all that but that's
besides the boy got a two dollar super
chat for dollar to talk so chick-fil-a
don't compete with mcdonald's
hey wait a minute i like this analogy
though i like this announcement oh no no
go go ahead uh ten dollar super chat
from
uh from donald taku saying this service
doesn't compete with xbox game passes
like saying the worst team in the nba
isn't competing with the best team just
because it's trash doesn't mean they
didn't build this to compete
i like that analogy because that's a
great analogy uh see like that's what i
was saying when i was explaining my
thoughts about this who is it for like
what is it for people say it's not a
game pass competitor yes i understand
they don't have day and day but it's a
service they already have services right
they already have ps now they already
have ps plus but they combine them and
they have three separate tiers why are
why are they doing this if they're not
trying to somehow
some way compete with game pass yes i
know they can compete as far as first
party day and date games
but it's still in my eyes they're trying
to compete and i love that analogy the
worst team like i'm a big detroit piston
fan you see
they're one of the worst teams in the
league at the moment
but last night they almost beat the
nets this is interesting
um i got something else for you guys i
don't know if you guys could see it but
someone said that they were scrolling
through xbox uh in
xbox game pass deals it seems like
pla um it seems like activision games
are already showing up on it
oh yeah i did see that yeah yeah right
there
i kind of wanted to respond to that nba
and now i don't know go ahead and
respond to it real quick all right with
the nba analogy with sports in
particular right
you
it's harder for you to go out and get
let's say a kevin durant right
absolutely to compete with the let's say
lebron james steph curry that list to go
on
all you got to do is put your you you
own the license to the games though you
own them joints it ain't no no middleman
playstation is y'all y'all is that he is
i and i am him right that's jay-z
reference i do believe it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter y'all own it so you
can drop them during day one if you want
to you just don't want to do it and
that's okay that you don't you don't
want to do it i get it i get it because
you you feel like it lessens the value
of it
hey look i'm not going to hold you i
wouldn't buy them games they wanted
either oh i wouldn't i wouldn't buy them
they went out i'll play them joints and
if i really like it i'll go back and
pick it up but no no i get it though i
get it but you can still easily just
flip that switch and be like all right
cool we're getting smoked we got to put
the new games on here now we got we got
to do what i mean like you can do that
the nba joint to me is like nah cause
you got to like really look for talent
if you want to build up or if you want
to do just but you know you can you got
to catch whoever in free agents you got
to catch them in traffic right places
don't got to catch none of the ips and
um free the free agent market they don't
gotta do all that they just now we got
them already here you go that's all they
got they can flip that switch and say
hey go and that's it i think that's just
me i do think what he was pretty much
saying is like
they still build these teams in these in
these sports to try to be the top team
like regardless if they fell or not and
a lot of that like i don't really keep
up with sports thing stuff but what it
seems like to me is it's always about
finances they can't afford the star they
need so they always try to like scout
one that can get just as much
perfect analogy
i want to mention one more thing another
reason why they're saying the direct
credit of the game play is
i don't care how many games over there
on xbox you can stream and download all
the og xbox joints all the xbox 360
joints and then you know last year
you can't do that with playstation for
some reason playstation 3 ain't there
and hey listen
um and i don't know if it has anything
to do with the sell architecture it
might it very well may right but if they
do yeah i want to see like i see now
many digital foundry shout out to john
lennon and the team over there i want to
like i want somebody to get to the
bottom of that because now i would love
to know why like if i'm paying for a
service why can't i get this one section
of games
from arguably its best lineup because
you know uncharted came out of that
lineup you know that's not how i feel
about that
i'm just saying i'm just saying but now
but it's just weird that you can only
stream those games you know what's weird
that's odd you're a love
for uncharted that's what's weird oh
come on we're not doing that we're not
doing that
yeah we started with chloe they started
with chloe you know
we got a five dollar series from dragon
heart yo tv
probably dracula yobe yeah
yo that's my boy hashtag peace love life
everybody stay safe attic dirt in this
greatness hustle keep grinding thank you
appreciate your generosity that's
we're going to be settling the podcast
about the the close it down you know uh
feeling generous today we'll answer like
maybe two or three questions in the chat
so if you guys want us to answer a
certain question
put a question mark in in
iron lore's podcast because i'm on the
iron lord's podcast chat you know i i'm
kind of curious to hear your guys's
thoughts on stuff now don't ask me about
stuff on dead labs don't ask me stuff
about like if you think if you feel like
i can't answer it don't ask me it please
because i will pr talk myself around
that with the quickness
[Laughter]
it's been been a good show man i can't
wait to get these new these new graphics
man because you know i i really do want
to make the podcast look more more
unique
i i have a couple things it's going to
look good
hopefully
obviously you know it's funny the dude
who did it because there's like a
revisions thing
it said like a hundred revisions
and i was thinking myself
i can make you work all year for the
money i just gave you
oh it's crazy man it's crazy you know
i don't think no one really wants to ask
us any questions which is it's okay
because then we could just end this
because uh
uh try to give you guys a little bit of
a
little bit a little bit of feedback man
you guys wanted uh to to engage in
something there's a lot of viewers i've
noticed that they just want to listen
they don't want to like they don't want
to talk in the chat or anything like
that game pass getting out in the ring
in may
unlikely
oh
you know be crazy if sony bought them
and elden ring came in
spartacus in june
that would be huge for them
yeah
how much height for the teenage mutant
ninja turtle collections rolls to your
veins zero how about you hustle
over here give it all here all of it
except turtles one cause i really like
children one too much but the rest of
them i'm going around um the um attack
of the foot clan or rise of the flick
clan on game boy i hear that's a pretty
good game so i'm gonna try that out for
the first time too i'm with it man
i'm down with it i'm down with it
i'm definitely
um
look for other questions in there while
i go look at first i apologize man when
that when the when the stuff was going
on i i when ign was stiping us uh
completely uh missed a lot of stuff i
don't know
homie [ __ ] j what's up bro five dollar
super chat from [ __ ] what's uh what's
up to my boy dirk game pass is king i
definitely apologize for that man
uh you know what's up
i'm trying to miss people on purpose
uh let's see we got a
five dollar strip chat from bobby gale
remind everyone developers create one
version of a game that plays on xbox pc
cloud huge advantage
yeah see the thing about that is i've
been told that sometimes that doesn't
work the greatest
that uh you know the best version you're
gonna get something that was created on
a dev kit like from beginning to end
uh because a lot of the times
some people some places like outsource
ports to another company like they're
not even directly working it uh so
that's interesting we got a five dollar
superchat from
bay area that's that's an interesting
name good show your shout out my man
dirt
hey ariel what's up homie brought a lot
of people up in here dirt
what's up yeah and friends and homies
man those people man they be there every
week for my podcast and my boy sean
podcast shout out to those folks bay
area aj angry therapists all you guys
there's nothing better than like
someone that just that's always there
that you can all man you can always
count on talking too man it's man it's
amazing uh just you know just knowing
that
years back i was just one of the guys in
the chat you know
listening to different shows and just to
know that people like actually listen to
my me like damn you know
it's dope man it's dope man
that's right but before we go dirk um
go ahead and let everybody know when
your podcast comes on and what day comes
on you know what type of uh energy can
we expect from your podcast oh yeah
absolutely now i'm gonna let you guys
know in advance if you're a playstation
fan boy
you might not want to listen to my
podcast
uh or even my videos lately uh but uh
check out my channel dirk griggity my
podcast is wbg xbox podcast on monday
evenings 6 30 p.m eastern standard time
and i also do um my boy sean 786 podcast
on fridays sometimes the time changes
sometimes because you know his work
schedule fluctuates
um it's called tts podcast xbox podcast
you know tts mean talk that you know
what um say that's what we do know we
have fun you know we you know we're xbox
fans we have fun i guess
part of it is just
revenge for last generation you know
xbox wasn't
you know xbox didn't give us any ammo
and and playstation fanboys beat my legs
and be all xbox fans legs last
generation so we're just having a little
fun man but it's all good no it's all in
fun man never take it personal but uh
yeah that's about it guys check it out
yeah i put his twitter in the chat
definitely go over there and uh give me
a follow
uh interesting individual i'm gonna i'm
gonna have him back on uh what's funny
is like
i wanna start getting some of the people
because i do have a developer coming on
soon he's been on iop before
uh he was the uh developer that worked
on halo
uh now
he works at respawn now uh i'm pointing
that out we're not asking questions
about where he works or where he came
from uh because i don't i want to bring
developers that have had on and
developers i'm going to meet in future
events and stuff and i want to talk
about the industry in general not what
they're working on because i want them
to feel like they're there to talk about
games and not there because of what they
do for a living
now obviously i'm going to ask them for
their
opinions about situations that that
current developers aren't off of
experiences that they've been in you
know uh i'm going to have a couple
people on
hopefully i got someone from 2k uh
hopefully he'll be coming on too
but you know
i definitely appreciate everyone for
coming through man uh next week i'm what
what
can i get my outro
well no i i didn't
jeez
what if i never gave you your outro
you know what you're right you're right
i'm still a little my adrenaline rushing
because of the dogs my fault them i'm on
edge
my father
as i was saying
we uh this this sunday you know uh
you're gonna wanna you're gonna wanna be
at iop this sunday man it's nice it's
gonna be crazy like king has been
talking
up
like crazy in the chat uh for those of
you don't know we will be at pax next
month i think it's like the 22nd i don't
know maybe the 26th it's one of those
days one day i'll wake up my phone will
say get on a plane that's how i'll know
uh you know i appreciate ever coming
through like i said we had a good amount
of people when you hit that like button
you know try to get that to above 150
before the end of the podcast hustle
give your outro
thank you thank you kindly um hey i'm
working on the ninja turtles video that
should drop saturday i got the footage i
need so i just got to record it that's
why i really got a haircut
also hey y'all in about a couple of
hours y'all make sure y'all go check out
the homie kiss move and the planet xbox
panel man go ahead check check my boy
out man
he's done so much for a lot of people
around here so if i could ever pay him
back i'm sure he knows this i would
definitely go ahead and help him the
best way to that campus y'all make sure
i check out planet xbox tonight as well
um and i'm wide the hell awake so i'll
probably be over there on that show too
yeah well i'm i'm finna go to bro i'm
tight
i'm mad
i'm surprised i'm here oh no sir yeah
see that's that's what i don't do that's
what i don't do i'll be in bed by a
hefty 8 45 sir i wake up too early in
the morning um no thank you all for
joining us um
yeah and you know and and dirk man you
know thank you for food for coming on
man like i said i saw you on ip and
everything and
i'll be seeing your thumbnails too
you'll be talking real reckless you
talking real spicy but i like it though
it's cool
you know
like sometimes people take it personal
like i mean like
like playstation is their girl or
something i'll just be having fun
i'll just be having fun bro
but i'm gonna tell you this before i go
i am a chloe stand man chloe frazier for
life and i'll just leave it at that but
um no no but y'all make sure y'all go
check out dirt dirk thank you thank you
i appreciate you guys man thank you
likewise
and i'm at it uh you know i'll see you
this sunday on iop for a very messy show
and uh we will definitely tune in yeah
we
uh you know what's crazy real quick uh
we are going to be setting up the e3
prediction sherry shows um you know i do
i'm kind of curious because i want to
have one on this sh this ch uh this show
too
uh probably go the reverse order the iop
goes iop usually saves uh the microsoft
one for last so we'll probably start
with that one first
uh so put in the comment section in the
the chat who would you like to see on a
on a xbox prediction show uh obviously i
do have a lot of reach into certain
develop certain people don't be saying
people that i you know realistically i
can't reach
like please don't don't be saying that
but anyway i appreciate it for coming
through man we'll see you next week on
the attic show uh on wednesdays at 5 00
p.m the reason we went to six today was
because uh hustle need to get a haircut
and uh griggity got off work and i
didn't want him rushing straight from
work straight to the podcast so i
delayed it an hour people literally put
in the chat 45 minutes late if you
didn't know follow me on twitter
i'll probably post stuff now sometimes
i'll just cancel a show won't even say
nothing but you know
but you know we've been consistent here
lately have we not
yes oh one thousand percent one thousand
percent right so you know i appreciate
everyone for coming through and until
next week
phil spencer here this is attic come out
of here please oh man
yo